let's think about another scenario
involving ratios in this case let's
think about the ratio
of the number of apples
number
of apples
two
accepting the ratio of the number of
apples to the number of oranges let's
take the number of apples to
the number
of fruit
the number of fruit that we have over
here and i encourage you to pause the
video and think about that on your own
well how many total apples do we have we
have two four six eight apples
so we're going to have eight apples and
then how much total fruit do we have
well we have eight apples and we have 3
6 9 12 oranges so our total fruit is 8
plus 12 we have 20 pieces of fruit so
this ratio is going to be 8
2
8 2
20. or if we want to write this in a
more reduced form we can divide both of
these by 4 4 is their greatest common
divisor and so this is the same thing as
a ratio 8 divided by 4 is 2 and 20
divided by 4
is 5.
so two two five now does this make sense
well if we divide if we divide
everything into groups of four
so or if we divide into four groups i
should say so one group
two groups
three groups
and four groups
and that's the largest number of groups
that we can divide these into so that we
don't have to cut up the apples or the
oranges we see that in each group for
every two apples we have one two three
four five pieces of fruit for every two
apples we have five pieces of fruit and
this is actually a good opportunity for
us to introduce another another way of
representing
another way of representing ratios and
that's using fraction notation so we
could also represent this ratio
as
2
over 5
as the fraction 2 over 5. whenever we
put it in the fraction it's very
important to recognize what this
represents this is telling us the
fraction of fruit that are apples
so we could say two-fifths of the fruit
of
the fruit
of the number of fruit i guess i could
save of number of fruit
of fruit
is equal to the number of apples right
let me just say two-fifths of fruit if
we're just speaking in more typical
terms
two-fifths
of fruit
are apples
are
are
apples
so once again this is introducing
another way of representing ratios we
could say that the ratio of apples to
fruit once again it could be two to five
like that it could be two instead of
putting this little colon there we could
literally write out the
word two
two to five
or we could say it's two-fifths the
fraction two-fifths which is which would
all sometimes be read as two to five
this is also
when it's written this way you could
also read that as a ratio depending on
the context in a sentence like this i
would read this as two-fifths of the
fruit
are
apples